for more we are joined now by Kenneth
Roth in New York he is the executive
director of Human Rights Watch thank you
very much for being with us now you say
that the rise of populism poses a
profound threat to human rights why is
that well what populism essentially is
our politicians who claim some special
insight into what the majority wants and
then claims that Trump's the rights of
the minority they claim that this this
majoritarian will is sufficient to
trample on minorities immigrants asylum
seekers refugees you know whatever the
vulnerable minority is and and that can
be popular with a public that is is
facing serious threats whether it's you
know economic dislocation caused by by
globalization and modernization whether
it's the cultural change caused by
immigration or even the threat of
terrorism
so in today's can a difficult
environment we feed see publics that are
susceptible to the appeal of the
populist and and it's frankly that is
why Human Rights Watch has issued a real
you know call a crisis to the general
public to stand up for human rights
values to to not fall for the simplistic
solutions offered by these populist s--
now you know one politician who you
mentioned has done that to great success
is us president elect Donald Trump for
example some might look at your report
and your criticism and say that it is
partisan how would you respond to that
critique well interesting I mean just a
couple days before
Human Rights Watch issued its annual
report I published a long critique of
the Obama administration's a-year human
rights record you know we are very much
bipartisan critics and we're not the
least bit partisan we hold every
government left or right Republican or
Democrat what-have-you to the same
international human rights standards and
indeed if you look around the world we
are critical of left-wing governments
like like President Maduro in Venezuela
as well as right-wing governments like
Vladimir Putin so we don't really care
about the partisanship we care about the
policies and what we see is that these
populist from a number of different
political person
are simply jettison human rights they're
saying that these are an obstacle to
what the majority wants we're going to
put them aside but frankly you know
we've seen how this works in the past we
saw communism and fascism these were all
about claiming the majority will justify
trumping the rights of a minority but
even today if you look at for example
President air21 in Turkey he had
tremendous popularity after he
suppressed the coup attempt this past
July but he then used that popularity to
suppress every conceivable critical
voice and as you mentioned you have tens
of thousands of people in prison many
just being journalists or or or
dissidents of some sort who criticized
Arawak and similarly in Egypt President
Sisi was very popular when he overthrew
the the Muslim Brotherhood government of
President Morsi but he then used that
popularity to utterly shut down an
independent press and independent civil
society any potential to criticize his
government so this is what happens when
you sacrifice the rights of just you
know an unpopular minority at first the
government's feel that they have license
to then gradually go after critics and
before you know it very few people have
any rights at all so given that why do
you think that the environment in Europe
in the u.s. is so ripe for the success
of populist movements like the brexit
campaign the rise of the far-right in
France the election of Trump that you
mentioned why now and what is the best
antidote I think that why now is because
there are a series of problems that
people feel their governments are not
answering and I just mentioned them it's
the economic dislocation I mean it's a
cultural change from immigration it's
the threat of terrorism and so you know
this is a difficult environment the
problem is the populace often don't
offer real solutions
you know Trump talks about undocumented
Mexican migrants in the United States
but in fact their net migration in
recent years has been zero and they take
jobs that Americans don't want and the
American economy is built on under
relatively cheap labor or if you took
you know in some of Europeans who are
promoting Islamophobia as an answer to
terrorism you just have hair builders
talking in those terms but of course the
last thing you want to do if you want to
fight terrorism effectively is to
discriminate against the Muslim
community because they're the ones the
most like beaten though
the stage of a potential tour spot the
police need their cooperation which they
won't get if official government policy
is Lama is Islamophobic so what we need
is for the public for both practical
reasons but also reasons of principle to
stand up to these populist is to say
these are not the answers to our
problems and these are not the kind of
intolerant hatred filled societies that
we want to live in we want to thank you
very much for your perspective Kenneth
Roth the executive director of Human
Rights Watch you have said that human
rights is under threat in leading
democracies due to the rise of populism
and we very much appreciate your
perspective